The best ones I go to are divided
between the ones that I will go to once
a month forever.
That I just,
I it,
you know,
I just
second there are all the time.
Love it.
I always go back for something that's a
part.
Then I check out almost every
significant new restaurant.
I live in New York,
so in New York,
but wherever I am,
I'm always interested in what's new,
what young chefs are doing,
what's going on.
And I'll go there once or twice
sometimes I get obsessed with a new
restaurant and I'll go every other day
for a month.
But um,
that's sort of like the new restaurant
piece and then there are major
restaurants that when I'm really almost
in a Rut when it comes to creating new
recipes or thinking about food I go to
because they're always inspirational.
They're always amazing and they,
they always give me something and sort
of restore my faith in cooking and
they're,
they're sort of the temples that are
necessary.
I'll give you a couple from each
category.
Uh,
the restaurants that I go to once a
month because they just feel great.
A bow is,
are the oyster bar grand central.
Um,
uh,
well let's just say those are two good
examples.
And I would put bond street actually in
that category.
Uh,
I would say all three of those are
places that are bustling.
The food is really excellent quality.
I mean,
in the case of oyster bar,
I only eat oysters there,
but the food,
the food is really excellent quality.
Uh,
and it's just a bustling,
great feeling place.
That's that.
That's that kind category.
The new restaurants,
like what's new and exciting.
You know,
I went to this place called del Anima
the other night,
which was really,
really good.
Really exciting.
Um,
this,
uh,
let me see.
New is always hard because it's a total
crapshoot.
You know,
you're,
I want to see what's going on and what's
out there and one out of 10 will be,
um,
will be terrific,
you know.
So right now for there's a kind of
Italian resurgence in New York,
actually.
A morality is not that new,
but that's a restaurant that I,
I ate at,
I would say,
you know,
I,
I got,
I got my credit card statement the other
day and it was like the only,
the only merchant on it was Miranda I
ate,
they're probably like,
you know,
20 times a month for three months.
And um,
I was just interested.
I thought the chef was doing certain
things I was really,
really interested in.
And um,
and then the,
the high holy restaurants that I have to
go back to.
Absolutely Babo.
I just think Mario Batali,
he can do no wrong in my book.
He's amazing.
And Babo is,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
You can't get a reservation there.
It's so difficult to get a reservation,
but.
So you would think that it's kind of
like,
oh,
so they get into a routine and it
doesn't have to be that great because.
And meanwhile,
every single time you go there,
you have something that you haven't had
before.
That's totally seasonal.
Brilliant.
It feels like it's existed forever,
except you've never actually had that
dish.
And it's genius.
And George,
I feel the same way it was on.
George is interesting to me because the
service there is so pristine that you,
it's just,
it's just a beauty super hold.
It's a beauty to feel
what modern perfect service can be like.
And then of course the food is always
interesting,
always exciting,
always.
Uh,
it always has flavors that are lovely
and wonderful.
And then there are those three
categories you can tell.
I absolutely love eating at restaurants.
Then of course there is ethnic food
which I eat a lot of and I mainly depend
on cab drivers for my recommendations.
And a,
there's just,
you know,
New York is just like a paradise for
that.